it's cold and dark a bitter unrelenting
snow surrounds you it's 3:00 a.m. and
you've been walking through downtown
Boston for over an hour you went to MIT
and you launched a successful startup
but that's over now
and all you can ask yourself is how did
I end up here you don't know and you
can't sleep see you walk that frigid two
and a half miles in the middle of the
night this is my life in November 2012 I
spent two years in the trenches building
my first real startup finally tasted
success only to watch it drift away I
had learned what it meant to rise and
now I was learning what it means to fall
Abraham Lincoln said that we are greedy
to publish the success of our efforts
but shy as to publishing our failures
and that we were ruined by this
one-sided practice of concealment of
blunders and failures for me that ends
today
this is a talk about falling one 19 1999
my family and I were about to drive back
home from dinner
I was busy playing one of the greatest
games of all time pokemon red that's a
great game
I caught a new Pokemon I was so excited
I ran into my mom but I didn't quite
make it
see I don't remember seeing the curb in
the parking lot that night but I
distinctly recall the taste of cement
when my face with the ground falling is
painful my mom picked me up and saw that
one of my two front teeth had been
pushed down and was now the better part
of two millimeters south of where it
should be not good we rushed to the
emergency room they told us to call the
dentist and he said I can see you in the
morning but by then it'll be too late if
you want to fix this you're going to
push it you're gonna have to push it
back up yourself I was ten
but these were permanent teeth and if
you feel queasy right now imagine how I
felt
I grabbed my mom's hand and squeezed as
hard as I could cry and pushing it one
two millimeters back into place and it
worked
see sometimes falling isn't a choice
but getting back up is investors and
startups often say that one of the
biggest risks and early-stage companies
is the team I couldn't agree more
let's go back to 2012 it was a bright
day in August and I went for a walk with
my co-founder as I often did but this
time something wasn't quite right the
summary had been a roller coaster ups
and downs and I could just feel it as we
were walking something was very wrong we
sat down to talk and I looked at him and
said what I could not believe but knew
to be true look you're gonna fire me
just do it and he did we started this
together and he fired me I went back to
the office at night to get my things and
I looked around and saw the company I'd
helped build and the products I'd helped
create and in that moment I felt like
I'd lost part of myself leaving the
startup was complicated
we both had leverage and we began to
negotiate I'd never done this before and
I made just about every mistake in the
book every time we come close to
reaching an agreement I just be
overtaken by fear and ask for something
new something more what should have
taken weeks turn into months I was
winning the negotiation mind you but at
the same time I was losing what was left
of our friendship I felt terrible but I
couldn't find a way out by Thanksgiving
I was burnout I was done what it started
as a simple negotiation
and become a chronic illness with no
cure but sometimes it's our darkest
moments that provide us with the
greatest clarity and from that low
vantage point it all made sense I had
become so afraid in Boston I hadn't just
lost my startup I had lost myself I had
forgotten about the future I knew then
that I had to stop trying to win so
that's what I did I forgave my friend
and I forgave myself fewer shares would
be enough this changed everything
between us and in that moment we became
old friends again and he even agreed to
help me sell enough shares to take a
year off you know it was one of those
win-win scenarios have always heard
about they actually do exist the process
wasn't easy but by the end of 2012 I was
free you know my greatest fear in
leaving the startup was not the money or
my reputation my greatest fear was
becoming a guy named Pete best now Pete
best was the first the original drummer
for The Beatles but you may not have
heard of him not because he missed out
but because shortly after leaving the
Beatles he didn't play a single show for
20 years Steve Jobs was fired from Apple
only after making the cover of Time
magazine but because he kept growing and
learning he ended up on the cover not
one but five more times I had a choice
to make when I keep growing would I keep
learning in my ear off I moved to Austin
Texas to build a live and work design
studio with my friends it was awesome
and Austin is an incredible place I
chose I chose Austin because it it's the
city where it's whatever you need it to
be and it would be my place to recharge
we ended up using the studio as this
incredible retreat and we invited all
kinds
people down to visit us entrepreneurs
musicians engineers screenwriters and
even a National Spelling Bee champion
King it was awesome
seriously there aren't that many but you
know we together we talked about falling
and what it takes to get back up again
and again I discovered that this is
called grit University of Pennsylvania
professor Angela Duckworth defines grit
as perseverance and passion for
long-term goals as she says that these
goals can take years even decades to
complete and her research shows that
this requires unwavering focus but wait
a minute wait a minute
if being gritty means sticking with your
goals then what about leaving the start
up how do these things match up so when
I got the chance to interview her I
asked about flexibility professor
Duckworth told me that less gritty
people have it backwards there were
little too flexible about their long
term goals and at the same time too
rigid about how they get their day to
day gritty people on the other hand or
the complete and total opposite dead-set
on their long term vision and at the
same time pretty flexible about how it
happens when you know where you want to
end up exactly which path you take is
less important on my path I had fallen
and though my time in Austin was an
absolute gift I knew that I couldn't
rest forever I came to Stanford to learn
about the future of hardware I came to
Stanford to learn about how to start
consumer brands that enchant the world I
came to Stanford to get back up and as
you walk on your path I can almost
guarantee that you will fall and then it
will hurt but remember that it's okay to
be flexible and sometimes you know it's
not just okay it's necessary grit is
having the patience and tenacity to keep
after it until you can get there no
matter which way you end up going
when you fall and when it hurts and when
that path grows dark in that moment of
doubt and pain remember what I have come
to know deeply your future our future is
brighter than the darkness thank you